so what's going on  with the project hello it's me emily  sparks coming to you from earth there's  a reason why you're not the most  liked girl at school i just don't want  to crush christopher's dreams of  communicating with aliens  emily we are so close to communicating  with whatever is out there  can you imagine what it's going to be  like when it finally happens  will he let us in it happened in this  town over 50 years ago  that there was only one eyewitness  frederick  munch you mean me mr munch his house is  totally haunted  the black eyed kids it's their harvest  in time  [Music]  so why do they ask you that question to  let them in because they have to  they need permission for whatever you do  never say yes sweetheart  the police will take care of it i want  you to stay put you guys  understand they're not a human you don't  know what they think  you think you'll get out alive  you